[Applause]
it's likely hold each other
yeah they don't even have each other's
find I've got like telepathic that one
outside your house just watching what
you were going to everything is leopard
so you do know I like an animal print
not afraid of that I'm really especially
when they're silky and salt I know that
looks like find yourself touching
yourself like this and people probably
feel like they're doing amazing like
it's just it's so fun to have like a
baby and she's like she's about to be
one and then the other kids they're just
getting so old now and they just like
have a mind of their own and it's just
are they too cool yet I mean like they
have better ideas than any of us it's
like like I'm like I have to ask Maxwell
if I look cute or not because I feel
like she would just look at me like why
wearing that you know oh my god my kids
since like they need to be positive with
me or something exactly you look
beautiful mommy I look horrible [ __ ] you
liar do your kids like it when you sing
yes they do I mean I didn't like growing
like with it with them growing up like I
didn't they didn't see me perform until
I got on stage with Willie Nelson right
before I found out I was pregnant with
birdy
oh wow yeah so it was it I I mean I sang
to them yes but like with my daughter
my firstborn Maxwell she like when I was
singing lullabies to her I was I was so
I was like this is not gonna make her
stop crying cuz it's like when the bough
breaks the cradle will fall and down
will come baby cradle and all everyone
dies and he dies and so I just sang
about America I sang the star-spangled
banner and I was like okay she's crying
so loud and I have some pipes and a set
of lungs so I can be louder than her so
I would just built out the star-spangled
banner
and now she sings it in the shower at
the top of her lungs
and she does such a great job so I take
credit for that that was me
your new book I mean as a fellow Texan
there could not be a better title for a
Texan a memoir is called open book yes
and is this like hard that you cuz
normally I would ask people is it hard
to share personal stories but I feel
like we might be similar and it's almost
cathartic it's such a you have no filter
like I have no filter I don't even I've
never had a future I think it's just
it's very important just to be yourself
and that's what's also tick and that's
what people love about especially this
book you open up about some pretty
personal stuff that's hard to get
through and most people I feel like
would be afraid to say that in the
public eye but it's so brave of you and
so cool of you and strong of you because
one when you address that then you know
you're actually getting past it yeah it
definitely like my openness holds me
accountable and for me like when I
decided to get sober I stopped drinking
and I just had so much clarity that with
my openness it was just like I started
learning so much about myself and why I
had to drink to like nice try and escape
and like and try and just feel like you
know just normal but that was you know I
thought it was like helping with my
anxiety and I was actually making it
worse yeah because people will say
they're like oh it's calming they say
that all the time we find it's all in
Italy not calm I know but I just think
it was really a brave of you to like
come out and say that and is it has it
been rewarding like getting it has it's
been unbelievable I've been on this book
tour and every city that I'm going into
it's like these people that come up to
me so like I you know I'm gonna be sober
like I'm I want to tell you first before
I tell my family and my parents and it's
connection yeah it's it's a really deep
connection and then I've had mother's
come up to me and I in like thanking me
and like they're not afraid of therapy
like for some reason people afraid we
are so afraid I'm in therapy I know I
love therapy it's like no judgment
yeah you can see whatever you want
they're not in your circle no it'll not
be judged it will not be and if you are
you don't know I'm you're paying them
yeah exactly
exactly I'm not your friend my therapist
at the very beginning I was like oh my
gosh I feel like we're best friends and
she goes I won't I want to make it very
clear that we're not friends I don't
know if anybody's ever said that to me
it's very clear yeah we're not friends
you know I've never asked one but now
I'm going to yeah it made me actually
want to make her be my friends cocoa
challenge open more yeah I'm like how
hard it'll what no I mean you're gonna
want me to be your daughter right the
end of this he felt that is a challenge
that's so Texan okay well Jessica's book
has been out for a little over a month
and even hit number one the New York
Times
[Applause]
look at that hair in that shot I love
your hair and as Jessica just mentioned
many of them were touched by someone
thinks that she wrote so would you be up
for us maybe taking a couple of
absolutely yes please well where is
Ramsey so Jessica I heard that you went
in a car accident and you quoted my
stutter started soon after and a doctor
said it was from the head injury my mom
said that when I started it looked like
my brain and I were trying to say 10
things at once my voice just wouldn't
work so from this trauma why did you go
into singing that actually singing was
the best way for me to communicate I've
heard about that so I got into singing
and that was literally the way that I
could express myself and how everything
like was clear so yeah I don't know what
caused the stuttering I mean it could it
could have been from the car accident
something you know like very traumatic
other traumatic things that I went
through as a child but and I also have a
million thoughts in my head at all time
me too like somehow trying to balance
that I might as well just sing through
it I love Matt I love that great
question so next question though it's
from Ashley right where's Ashley at hi
Ashley hi Kelly hi Jessica
talk about being sober and you're
actually just speaking about it now what
brought you to the point where you felt
like you had to get sober well being a
mother like I mean my kids at the time
were five and four so I I grew up with
no alcohol in the house and I was but I
mean I was at a place where I was
literally like spiraling with the
alcohol like and but I and I was missing
out moments of like missing out on
moments with my children and then they
were seeing me and they were very
confused and I I just wanted to be
present and have and have clarity and be
a good role model for my children
because I always wanted to be a good
role model for the world so why in the
world would I like be stuck in the cycle
of having to like wake up and have a
drink before going to one of their
school assemblies
got to the point where all of my life
had like escalated and I I couldn't
suppress it and alcohol it wasn't it
wasn't working it was making me just
completely check out and not be there
for them funny and then you feel like
cuz when you're at the height of your
career people always think you're the
happiest the height of my career I was
the most miserable right and I just
wanted to quit because I was like this
isn't worth it I was a really good
waitress it's like I'm just constantly
battling just to be me which is
exhausting yeah you know so it's it's
it's interesting to my kids but I also
realized in the process I was doing it
for myself you know like I really wanted
to go back to the perspective that I had
when I was younger for a movie or show
ya know your fashion line like
everything you do is that hits everyone
lunch her shoes I realized her hair
everybody loves everything you do so I
mean what's the latest thing you're
doing with the fashion line like
everything is so natural it's like when
I was pregnant we did maternity and then
after I'd had a baby I was like oh like
why in the world can we not snap these
buttons in the correct way and so we put
like a different color the button where
like where the diaper is starts to
separate it's so annoying annoying so I
mean everything's been very natural and
we've had such great success with the
Jessica Simpson Collection Anna and we
never had ecommerce and so we just
launched Jessica Simpson comm and
they're like over this last year yeah
and it's been doing amazing because then
I get to blog and then people can really
connect to me and know the world of me
so now I mean I mean sky's the limit for
the brand and we're just now doing
e-commerce so it's it's been just
growing and there's just so much more
like I want stores and I want furniture
and I mean my daughter wants a dog line
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going